hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel I today am very excited to
finally give you a two of my animal
crossing island I just thought that I
would do something fun and light-hearted
but I didn't want to let you all know
that I am still taking donations at the
link below the campaign ends I believe
on Monday for the Minnesota freedom fund
if you can donate that would be
absolutely awesome but otherwise enjoy
the animal crossing so I thought that I
would show you the island during dusk it
is getting a bit late but you know just
some soft tones this is obviously the
airport
we walked just straight up I'll take you
past some of the houses and just go
straight to the town square here because
I feel like this is kind of a good
starting point so this is oh hello I
have a koala his name is Yuka oh no I
didn't I super didn't I did not hear
shaved-ice great love that actually -
absolutely no credit of my own I have
where is it I go to the map a slice
technically an alligator I think but I
call in a crocodile a kangaroo and a
koala and then a million stupid mice but
this is what looks like you know we've
been doing some terraforming out here so
yeah this is this is the town square
area apple trees here these are my local
fruit I let any guest who wants to come
by take the apples just a shawarma and
flowers while I'm at it we sawed off to
this side I just have a cute little kind
of outdoor dining area a little cafe I
like to call it with a nice water
fountain where you can you know sit down
and play you could talk beachfront here
I'm gonna take that similar thing you
know soft board just just places to
chill you know and then if we come
across what it's fireflies out that's
new we come across this bridge this is I
guess the area that's like the lead-up
to my museum which naturally is up here
lots of bamboo and imperial decorating
out here I really love this area on its
lead is like jam-packed with nice
designs and stuff that I like I like the
fact that it is both cohesive and not
cohesive and then it's not entirely a
bamboo
this little area I love this it's like a
little place to you know sit down and
have some snacks and then if you want to
follow this red carpet custom design
very complicated to make you know you
can come over here and you can press
this belt going brother you do you and
then if we head up the back here you
know just got this spooky guest waiting
for you just hanging out being spooky
little easter egg up the islands so
we're gonna come back down so if we're
back in a cafe here I'm gonna take you
guys this way this area is sort of a
shout out to home for me I'm slouching
so bad right now today oh my god I did
damn white people [ __ ] for anyone who
doesn't know I was born in a place
called Cannes in Australia which has a
thing called the Esplanade the Cannes
Esplanade not that can zones Esplanade
but it's basically like a really
eclectic stretch or at least it was when
I was a kid of markets and that's kind
of what I made this look like it's just
a bunch of stuff on the beach that looks
really messy like very intentionally
looks really messy it just kind of made
me feel like home my little my little
market area just a little ode to
Australia if the kangaroos and that
Camel and koala the crocodile want
enough sending a little beachfront fit
here I don't feel like any of this Beach
stuff is particularly impressive but you
know then you got a little radio there
in a book coconuts and a little
lighthouse all very cute so now I'll
show you guys the houses I suppose this
is just kind of like a little mini pakka
kind of Reading area for the people who
live here so if we circle back around
you know this is back whether the
airport is and I tried to just make the
fences around each house or the design
around each house kind of matched the
house like I love this that it's you
know blue fence with a wooden broad cage
and a blue and brown wood house with a
little um wouldn't it what's it
what is it called clothes line on the
side it's one stone a bit Zen you know
just hanging out in your backyard you
can't get to where you have a bird pond
and a time sand thing what a way I like
this one too nice same on the other side
houses just hanging out being houses
these are less elaborately designed than
the ones on the other side obviously you
know pong table or whatever there's
another Beach obviously at the front
hand a little place where you can sit if
you would like oh you could also sit
here if you would like many options I
never see my village is sitting in any
of these things I love that sandcastle
though this is my gym my beachfront gym
got all the basics really a whole thing
I don't get more gym stuff because I
sure as hell don't have anywhere to put
it but you know you got a little
diffuser here for everyone smelling bad
and you have protein shakes and stuff it
is what it is we we about it
just the smallest game of soccer slash
football ever if you walk up here this
is my kind of kids play area just a big
playground where the non-existent
children because I don't have any in
this town can I hang out I keep my money
trees here in between the houses like a
little communal money tree garden and
then again just a reference to town
squares right here this is my nook
cranny that I've just expanded on either
side to look like they have like a sort
of outdoor area with some extra stuff
and a little place where you can have a
coffee because that I think was kind of
inspired by my favorite coffee shop in
San Francisco which is also a book shop
and like a store and has this cute
outdoor area but that's probably exactly
what I'm image shout-out to crossroads
if we keep walking this way my able
sisters again I just try to expand
everything kind of on both sides
across the bridge if we go let's go up
first this is my sort of European area
as I am wanted to call it that's
exciting but just like a sort of Dutch
maybe you know Holland vibes I don't
know but I did kind of design this whole
I'm like a theme park where it's very
much split into section it's like this
is clearly a section design for things
that look like this though a lot of
brick and a lot of wood it's very like
segmented in that way right here before
we go any further it's just supposed to
be like a little stuff sit down you
could do some homework you can use some
utensils you do you down here is one of
the only parts I haven't completely
finished that I didn't want to keep
waiting for to show you guys is what I'm
sort of calling a Botanical Gardens I've
got all my flowers that I bred the
colors like split up into different
sections obviously fading into each
other kind of so like if you come around
it this way these are all purple they
don't look as purple when it's nighttime
but they are and then yellow and keep
coming down here it's just just a nice
little garden to walk through I think
with a little nice garden path this is
the area that I need more blue flowers
before I will feel like this is
completed what we're getting there and
then this is my campground again cuz I
can't just have something beefs a
certain way I have to expand it so
you've got you know a little porta
potties back there a place where people
come and hang out and eat there's like a
little wash area here there's one caught
there if anyone wants you know take it
cute
the campgrounds the actual like in-game
campgrounds a little fire you know how
it be they seriously like up to the
quality on the weeds recently and I do
leave weeds in this area specifically I
just try to take it off at pops but I
kind of like that it looks a bit of the
grown I think that's suits the vibe
Beach here not terribly exciting just
some more of each stuff I I think I
might add some more towels too and
that's the thing that I should make
effort to do but yeah just you know
beachy things happening so many options
you know in quarantine II as my island
is cold I should get that
I don't want to do it do the tour all on
it so let's go this way first
I built this red carpet by hand which is
why it's sort of bad I'm not a pixel
artist I did my best in a lot of ways
here so this is my red carpet but what
does it lead to anyone who watched my
stream will know it leads to a pokemon
stadium I also built this by hand there
is the stream of me building this and
going insane because I was kind of tipsy
trying to make these look as circular as
possible is still available on my
channel but yeah this is you know you
have you little host here if you would
fit doesn't you know it's not real so
who cares you know to commentate your
Pokemon match where you would stand here
and you would you know throw your
Pokemon in that is where you'd have the
concession to got a little cheap box
there and a camera that's just surveying
all the action and then you know a
little toilet and a and an outhouse out
here this pot I really put some thought
into because this was my last decades
and I was like is this what I want to
use it on but I got my waterfall
backdrop there and in theory this is
what you would win if you were to win
the theoretical Pokemon match it doesn't
exist come down here this is sort of
like a bit of a space filler really I
wish I had a bit more grasp who have
made this a little bit wider here and
yeah I've intentionally not grown this
tree but this is supposed to be a Zen
garden the sand here was a custom design
I did not make it that's one that I got
from reddit yeah just a little you know
and then gone and got stuff you know
just that I felt suited the area
he's just also just kind of random stone
stuff that I felt sued in this area this
is my power farm got a got a power the
island somehow ladies and gentlemen with
another white house out here okay back
here we come up do the left is my little
alto Dinah I think it's cute I kind of
tried to make it a bit eclectic so that
it really looks like it was kind of made
by someone who pieced it together and it
was homey or whatever like the couch was
up there I don't necessarily match but
you know I try to match the lampshades
to the couch
so Dinah with you know some games and
then there's a piano and a guitar back
here I think it's cute just a little
outdoor diner that's what I like and
then up here is my graveyard entirely
black flowers
he's one Sabretooth because I felt like
it just looked cool peeping out from
behind the tree they're not that many
graves that's something I could probably
do with some moral frankly but they're
all some little spooky cafe no coffee
lose spooky dolls so that's the
graveyard and then it's time to take you
to my home and up to but the French
gardens hedges everywhere this is where
I would put the Statue of David if I had
one
probably instead of that stupid
terrarium there yeah this is designed to
literally look like a French garden lots
of hedges and just like they're all
white flowers out here except for the
blue bushes another apple tree cuz
that's my little tree places to sit just
kind of hang out by the well I should
probably get rid of that flower that's
not meant to be there this is just a
convenient stepping star to jump across
to the museum area really nothing major
and then you can come up here this is
sort of the pool area that leads to my
house places to sit have a cute little
picnic you know how it is with all your
friends just a nice place
some babe or whatever over this side is
my little outdoor restaurant this like
fish show feels like the backyard that I
had as a kid
or it was like this color brick and a
little outdoor pizza oven
even these kind of chairs and just lots
of plants in pots like I've just like
made some of this nostalgic whatever
recently maybe I miss home and then up
here's on my house actually is which I'm
not proud of because like clearly I left
the stupid thing on the door that's
right
stupid wreath from east oh I'm gonna
change the color of that as soon as I
can and they just got the ability to
expand it and I owe seven hundred
thousand bells for it so it's whatever
we'll figure it out don't worry about it
but I like this little area and this is
kind of an area where you'd sit outside
and right and Stargate if you would if
you would like to do that coming back
here
this is Stata my olkin my design it's a
little bit so that it kind of looks like
a winery but yeah I have my rows of
there are like two things I should dig
up right here of different kinds of
fruit trees places to sit everywhere
more rows of fruit trees this little bit
is here because that's where bread comes
I was originally gonna have a staircase
leading down to red but it goes down to
more grass and then goes down to stones
and you can't put staircases on stone so
that staircase went to the Pokemon
Stadium instead once you've gone through
the orchids um I call this the lake I
feel like this is just like I pictured
people hanging out and going for a swim
you know again it's absolutely like a
place I used to go to when I grow up
this is a place called Lake Placid in
Cannes I I didn't realize the psychology
behind what I've done to this island
before I made this video and I had to
explain what I've done to this island I
need therapy
this is just where I grow the very
particular kinds of flowers that I want
to oh hey little [ __ ]
whoa is he gonna attack me I don't know
how to do this really like like oh my
gosh yes
oh well I guess I'm swapping something
yes I'm trying to go black here cuz I
need more of those for the graveyard
trying to blue here black for those two
yeah I mean that work put them right on
that black goes to so yeah just trying
to grow some flowers and I think that's
the whole island I think that's it it's
very full like I said it's very very
structured I let all my fruit grow for a
few days and my money trees and stuff
for the purposes of making this video to
make it look complete but really the
only other things that I want that I
don't have so far yeah more more
statue-like things for this area I would
like different animals that would be
great I would love some dogs Oh simple
so something rather than all these
stupid mice but that's that's pretty
much it I'm proud of it and I hope you
guys picking up what I'm putting down
this is quarantine II very specifically
called that because I don't feel like I
will touch this game very much outside
of seasonal events outside of isolation
so thank you for watching